في بدايه 15 مايو سنه
1948 تحديدا منتصف الليل اعلنت بريطانيا
انهاء احتلالها لفلسطين وانسحابها منها
وبعدها بساعات قليله اعلن المجلس اليهودي
بقياده ديفيد بن جوريون تاسيس دوله يهوديه
في فلسطين او اللي احنا نعرفه بالكان
المحتل وقبلها وعلى مدار عقود كانت عمليات
الاستيطان اليهودي في ارض فلسطين شغاله
بقوه بفضل المؤسسات الصهيونيه النشطه في
العالم وبتشجيع من بريطانيا طبعا اللي
مكنت اليهود من السيطره على مسحات كبيره
من الاراضي الفلسطينيه المهم بعد اعلان
قيام الدوله الصهيونيه في فلسطين وهزيمتها
للدول العربيه في حرب
1948 واجهه الدوله الناشئ انهيار اقتصادي
في بدايه الخمس سنات ايوه من اولها كده
وقتها رئيس الوزراء بن جورين ووزير
الماليه ليفي اشكول اضطروا ياخدوا اجراءات
اقتصاديه وماليه مؤلمه لمنع الانهيار
الاقتصادي وفناء الكيان الوليد اللي كانوا
بيحلموا بيه لدرجه انهم وقفوا هجره اليهود
لاسرائيل وجوزيف زيرا استاذ الاقتصاد في
الجامعه العبريه في القدس بيقول ان بن
جوريون وقتها ادرك ان دي نهايه المشروع
الصهيوني لان هدفه من تاسيس الكيان المحتل
انه يبقى موطن ل الشعب اليهودي ولكن اللي
حصل هو انه فجاه تم حظر موجات الهجره بسبب
الضائقه الاقتصاديه في خلال النص الاول من
الخمسينات قدرت دوله الاحتلال تنجو من
الاعصار الاقتصادي اللي كاد يقضي عليها
بسبب ثلاث حاجات اولا اتفاقيه التعويضات
مع جمهوريه المانيا الاتحاديه سنه
1952 مع تعويضات الناجين من المحرقه وفروا
لها شويه فلوس كويسه ثانيا مساعدات بعض
الدول الكبرى اللي جريت تنقذها زي
الولايات المتحده ومساعدات اليهود
الاثرياء في العالم ثالثا بقى وده الاهم
استيلائها على الاصول المملوكه لمئات
الالاف من الفلسطينيين اللي تم تهجيرهم
قصرا بعد هزيمه
1948 وسابوا وراهم اراضي ومنازل كتير جدا
وبالتالي حطت دوله الاحتلال ايدها على
اصول غنيه جدا وده انقذها من الانهيار
الاقتصادي وبدات بعدها تقف على رجليها
تاني وتعيد بناء اقتصادها بعد مرور 70 سنه
قدر الكيان المحتل اللي قام على اغتصاب
ونهب وسرقه الارض واللي عليها يبني ثاني
اكبر اقتصاد في منطقه الشرق الاوسط بعد
السعوديه اقتصاد تجاوز حجمه 521 مليار
دولار رغم صغر عدد سكانه اللي لم يتجاوزوا
10 مليون نسمه الاقتصاد ده ما فيش حاجه
بتعطل ولا بتستنوا غير حاجه واحده بس
المقاومه الفلسطينيه مع كل عمليات مقاومه
بتقع ضد الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الاقتصاد
بتاعهم بياخد بالقلم على وشه في 7 اكتوبر
2023 بدات المقاومه الفلسطينيه تشن هجوم
مباغت وقوي على الكيان المحتل زي ما
حضراتكم متابعين على مدار الايام اللي
فاتت وهنا اكيد في سؤال رئيسي شاغل بالنا
كلنا وهو ازاي ده بياثر على اقتصاد دوله
الاحتلال وفي سؤال ثاني اهم هو ليه المره
دي بالذات مختلفه في تاثيرها عن اي مرات
فاتت قبل كده ده اللي هنحاول نجاوب عليه
مع بعض في حلقه النهارده باذن الله عاوز
انبهكم قبلها لحاجتين مهمين جدا اول حاجه
ان الحلقه دي كل ارباعها هتروح لاهلنا في
غزه ان شاء الله دي اقل حاجه ممكن نعملها
لاهلنا هناك وهنعرف الجهه وهن اوريكم وصله
تبرع بعد ايام وتاني حاجه ان المواقع
ومنصات التواصل الاجتماعي عامله قيود
كبيره على انتشار المحتوى المضاد لدوله
الاحتلال فهمتكم معانا باللايك والشير
والتفاعل مع الفيديو علشان يظهر للناس
ويزيد مبلغ التبرع با باذن الله انا اشرف
ابراهيم ده المخبل
[موسيقى]
الاقتصادي قبل ما نبدا انا وفريق المخبر
الاقتصادي واعتقد كل واحد من حضراتكم برده
هنكون حابين نشكر جدا شركه تلفيت راعي
حلقتنا النهارده اللي بدره كتر خيرهم
وبعتوا لنا ودفعوا اضعاف المبلغ اللي
بيدفع في المعتاد في رعايه اي حلقه عندنا
علشان يدعموا اهلنا في غزه من خلال مؤسسه
مرسال الخيريه المصريه الموثوقه شركه تلا
فيت اتاسس سنه 2017 وهي شركه فيتناميه
اسسها شاب مصري مكافح اسمه ضياء الدين
امين وبتصدر لاسواق مصر والسعوديه والاردن
وتركيا وغيرها منتجات مختلفه زي البن
والفلفل وجوز الهند والقرفه والكاجو زي ما
قلنا لحضراتكم مبلغ الرعايه كله راح
لمؤسسه مرسال اللي مشاركه حاليا في توفير
مواد اغاثه من ادويه وغذاء لاهلنا في غزه
وبالفعل قوافلهم موجوده قدام معبر رفح وان
شاء الله تدخل قريب كما نتمنى واحتمال
تكون دخلت وانتم بتشوفوا التسجيل ده حابب
برده اشكر كل الشركات المحترمه اللي بعتت
لنا علشان طرع الحلقه دي لكن احنا اخدنا
اكبر مبلغ اتعرض علشان زياده الاستفاده
وبطمن ان الحلقه الجايه برده مقابل
رعايتها هيروح بالكامل لدعم اهلنا في
فلسطين ففي فرصه ثانيه تساهموا معانا ثاني
وهنعلن ده لكم على منصاتنا اول ما تدخل
الحلقه الجايه الانتاج باذن الله هتلاقوا
تحت الفيديو بيانات شركه تلا فيت لو في
شركه او تاجر حابب يتعامل معاهم ويستورد
من خلالهم المنتجات دي يا ريت تعملوا ده
وهتلاقوا بيانات مؤسسه مرسال برده للي
حابب يتابع الانشطه اللي بيقوموا بيها
حاليا لدعم اخواتنا الفلسطينيين والنشاط
الخيري بتاعهم بشكل عام لو بصينا على دوله
الاحتلال هنلاقي انه من اكث القطاعات
الحساسه اللي بتدر دخل ليها هو قطاع
السياحه اي مواجهات او حروب يا اخوانا
بتحصل معاها هنلاقي ان القطاع ده في فيها
بيتضرب في مقتل فورا وفقا لاحدث الارقام
الصادره عن مكتب الاحصاء المركزي
الاسرائيلي في شهر يوليو اللي فات ففي
الشهور السته الاولى من السنه دي 2023 زار
اسرائيل اكثر من 2 مليون سائح انفقه حوالي
3.1 مليار دولار وده رغم ان قطاع السياحه
هناك لسه بيتعاطى بسبب قيود كوفي 19
والحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه وبالتالي كان
متوقع ان السنه دي يدخل جيب الكيان المحتل
اكتر من 6 مليار دولار من قطاع السياحه بس
ولكن في ظل هجوم المقاومه الفلسطينيه ومع
اطاله امد الحرب فالار دي هتقل كتير وده
بان من اول ساعات الهجوم لما بدات شركات
الطيران العالميه تلغي مئات الرحلات
الجويه المتجهه للاراضي المحتله معظم
شركات الطيران الامريكيه والاوروبيه
والاسيويه والافريقيه الغت رحلاتها لتل
ابيب لحد نص شهر ديسمبر على الاقل وفي
شركات علقت الرحلات لحد نهايه ديسمبر لحد
ما تشوف الوضع الامني هيوصل لف ايه وفي
اللي راح ابعد من كده ولغى رحلاته الجويه
اربع شهور قدام زي عملاق الطيران الفنلندي
شركه فينير اللي وقفت رحلاتها لتل ابيب
لحد 30 مارس 2024 الغاء الرحلات الجويه
بالكثافه دي مش بس هيحرق الكيان المحتل من
تدفق عشرات الالاف من السياح وبالتالي
التاثير على ايراداته السياحيه ولكنه كمان
اثر على اسهم شركات الطيران نفسها يعني
يوم 9 اكتوبر اللي فات وبعد يومين من هجوم
المقاومه الفلسطينيه تراجع مؤشر بلومبيرج
لشركات الطيران العالميه بنسبه
2.6% وهو اكبر انخفاض يحصل في يوم واحد من
شهر مارس اللي فات لما افلست بعض البنوك
الامريكيه ورغم ان معظم شركات الطيران
العالميه الغت رحلاتها المتوجهه لتل ابيب
ففي شركه طيران واحده بس كانت مكلفه بمهمه
مختلفه شويه ومهمه ليهم لدرجه انها شغلت
رحلات اضافيه كمان لنقل اشخاص معينين من
دول مختلفه لداخل اسرائيل الشركه دي هي
شركه الطيران الاسرائيليه الرئيسيه العال
ومهمتها ببساطه هي نقل الاف من جنود
الاحتياط كجزء من اكبر تعبئه في تاريخ
الكيان المحتل وده ياخدنا لاهم وابرز شيء
مؤلم لاقتصاد دوله الاحتلال وهو استدعاء
جنود الاحتياط وهنعرف بعد شويه ليه ده
مؤلم جدا للاقتصاد في صباح يوم 9 اكتوبر
استدعى الكيان المحتل 300000 جندي احتياط
اسرائيلي للخدمه وصلوا بعد كده 360,000
جندي وهو اكبر استدعاء عسكري في التاريخ
الحديث للاحتلال الاسرائيلي الكيان الزفر
ده ما استدعا قوات احتياط بالحجم ده من
حرب اكتوبر
1973 قبل 50 سنه واللي استدعى فيها 400000
جندي احتياط وقتها علشان حضراتكم تتخيلوا
ال 360,000 جندي دول يتجاوزوا العدد
الاجمالي لجنود الاحتياط في الجيش
الامريكي باكمله ولو بصينا على قوات جيش
الاحتلال النظامي الدائمين نفسهم هنلاقي
ان عددهم سواء القوات البريه او الجويه او
البحريه كلهم على بعضهم اول عن اخر هم نص
العدد المستدعى يعني بنتكلم في 150,000
شخص بس ليه بقى استدعاء العدد الضخم ده من
قوات الاحتياط بياثر جامد على اقتصاد
الكيان المحتل لان قوه الاحتياط دي عباره
عن شريحه واسعه من القوى العامله المؤثره
في الاقتصاد عباره عن مهندسين تقنيين
واصحاب مشاريع ناشئه ومعلمين ومزارعين
ومحامين واطباء وممرضات وفنيين في المصانع
وعمال في قطاع السياحه القوى العامله
الضخمه دي فجاه بتسيب اماكنها وبتروح
تنخرط في حرب ممكن تقعد اسابيع ايال وينتر
استاذ الاقتصاد في الجامعه العبريه في
القدس واللي درس الاثر الاقتصادي لحروب
اسرائيل بيقول ان تاثير سحب القوى العام
مله الضخمه دي بشكل مفاجئ كبير على
الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي طب ليه سحب العدد
الضخم ده من سوق العمل للانضمام للعمليه
العسكريه يعتبر كارثيه لاقتصاده لان
ببساطه ده حؤديد ليل عرض العماله في سوق
العمل الاسرائيلي اللي هو ضيق اصلا
وبالتالي ده هيؤه طل النشاط الاقتصادي وده
بطبيعه الحال هيؤدى خنق عرض السلع
والخدمات وبالتالي هيتسبب في ركود تضخمه
يعني ارتفاع في معدل التضخم مع انخفاض في
معدل النمو الاقتصادي طبعا حجم الضرر
الاقتصادي هيعتمد على مده بقاء جنود
الاحتياط بعيدا عن وظائفه لحد دلوقتي
تقديرات بتشير الى ان الحرب هتقعد اسابيع
وده معناه تفاقم الضرر الاقتصادي للكيان
المحتل الخبر السيء للاسرائيليين هنا ان
الكلام ده جاي في وقت اقتصادهم بيعاني فيه
بالفعل وكان بيسير في اتجاه نمو هبوطي طب
ايه سبب المعاناه دي السبب انه من بدايه
السنه وال الحكومه الاسرائيليه بقياده
بنيامين نتنياهو بدات في الدفع لاجراء
اصلاحات قضائيه بعدها بدات سلسله من
الاحتجاجات المعارضه للاصلاح ده وده خلق
حاله من عدم اليقين في الاقتصاد والسوق
وادى لتباطؤ الاستثمارات وبالذات في اهم
قطاع اللي بيعتبر محرك النمو الرئيسي
للكيان المحتل و هو قطاع التكنولوجيا
الفائقه علشان كده مكتب الاحصاء المركزي
الاسرائيلي كان توقع في شهر فبراير اللي
فات تباطؤ النمو الاقتصادي في اسرائيل
بشكل حاد ل 3% في سنه 2023 بعد ما وصل ل
6.5% السنه اللي فاتت 2022 وهنا لازم نقف
شويه عند اهم قطاع اقتصادي للكيان المحتل
واللي يمكن اغلبكم اتفاجئ لما عرف انه
قطاع التكنولوجيا الفائقه واللي بالمناسبه
متوقع انه ياخد ضربه محترمه بسبب استدعاء
جنود الاحتياط قطاع التكنولوجيا المتقدمه
ده هو اللي بيقود النمو الاقتصادي لدوله
الاحتلال يا اخوانا لك ان تتخيل انه بيسا
ساهم في نص صادرات اسرائيل وفقا لوزاره
الاقتصاد الاسرائيليه فالكيان المحتل صدر
سلع وخدمات ب 10065 مليار دولار تقريبا
السنه اللي فاتت 2022 51% من الصادرات دي
كانت صادرات تكنولوجيا متقدمه زي البرمجه
والبحث والتطوير واشباه المواصلات وهنا حد
اكيد مستغرب وبيسال ايه اللي جاب صناعه
متقدمه جدا وعليها صراع عالمي زي اشباه
المواصلات لاسرائيل للاسف رغم ان دوله
الاحتلال كيان صغير الا ان تاثيرها كبير
في صناعه اشباه المواصلات العالميه وهي
بتعتبر حلقه مهمه في سلسله توريد الرقائق
الالكترونيه في العالم ففضلا عن انها مصدر
رئيسي للمواهب الهندسيه فهي مركز لمصنعي
اشباه الموصلات الدوليين وفيها شركات نشئه
كتير محليه شغاله في مجال اشباه الموصلات
واللي نسبه كبيره منها بيتم الاستحواذ
عليه من قبل الشركات العالميه الكبرى مش
عارف حضراتكم تعرفوا ولا لا شركه انتل
اللي هي عملاق تصنيع اشباه المواصلات
موجوده في اسرائيل من 50 سنه تقريبا
وعندهم مواقع لتصميم وانتاج الرقائق
الالكترونيه في جميع انحاء اسرائيل شركه
انفيديا اللي بتعتبر اكبر مصنع لاشباه
المواصلات المستخدمه في انظمه الذكاء
الاصطناعي موجوده في اسرائيل بقوه شركه
ابل موجوده برض
وبتصميم الخاص بها في اسرائيل شركه امازون
وشركه مايكروسوفت موجودين ولهم مراكز مهمه
لتصمييم الرقائق الالكترونيه وغيرهم من
الشركات هجمات المقاومه الفلسطينيه بتهدد
الصناعه الحيويه دي في اسرائيل وفي حاله
من الرعب في القطاع الحساس ده يكفى اقول
لك انه من بين الاسرائيليين اللي اثرتم
حركه حماس من الحفل الموسيقي هنلاقي مهندس
شغال في شركه انفيديا اسمه افينا تان اور
وشركه انفيديا اكدت الخبر وبعيدا عن ده
فاغلب الشركات دي قالت ان جزء كبير من
موظفي فيها تم استدعائه ضمن الاستدعاء
الجماعي لجنود الاحتياط وده ادى لاضطرابات
كبيره في اماكن العمل تاثير استدعاء العدد
الضخم ده من جنود الاحتياط ما بيقفش هنا
بس ولكن بيساهم مع التكاليف العسكريه
الثانيه من واردات اسلحه وغيره لزياده
الانفاق العسكري في ملايين الدولارات
بتتحرق كل يوم في العمليات العسكريه وده
بيزود من عجز الموازنه الاسرائيليه ليه
بقول بيزود لان الموازنه الاسرائيليه كانت
بتعاني من عجز مال اصلا بمعنى ان الحكومه
بتصرف اكت من اللي بيدخل لها وعجز
الموازنه في الوقت ده بالذات هيحط حكومه
نتانياهو في ورطه كبيره وهقول لكم ازاي
بعد شويه بس قبلها عاوز اوضح لكم حجم
العجز في موازنه الكيان المحتل ده اللي
قدام حضراتكم ده هو بيان للموازنه العامه
الاسرائيليه صدرت في شهر اغسطس اللي فات
واللي بتظهر زياده العجز المالي ل 1.3% من
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي وده بيعادل 6
مليار دولار في ال 12 شهر اللي فاته العجز
المالي ده بسبب استمرار انخفاض ايرادات
الدوله من الضرايب وزياده الانفاق الحكومي
عن المبلغ المقدر في الميزانيه وطبعا
الانفاق الحكومي ده هيزيد بعد العمليات
العسكريه بسبب زياده الانفاق الدفاعي فضلا
عن نفقات اعاده الاعمار وتعويض فقدان
الدخل للموظفين والتدابير الامنيه الجديده
وبالذات بعد فشل الجدار الحديدي اللي
بيفصل ما بين قطاع غزه وباقي الاراضي
المحتله واللي قعدوا يبنوا فيه ثلاث سنين
ونص وتكلف 1.1 مليار دولار طب ليه العجز
المالي ده يعتبر ورطه بالنسبه للحكومه
الاسرائيليه لانها مضطره تمول العجز ده
وهنا في طريقتين اصعب من بعض اما تضطر
تقترض اموال اضافيه وهنا هتتلوي من اسعار
الفايده العاليه الحكومات الفتره دي علشان
تقترض بتقترب بالغالي بسبب الارتفاع
الجنوني في اسعار الفايده على مستوى
العالم كله اما الطريقه الثانيه لتمويل
العجز ده فهي زياده الضرايب وده خيار صعب
وهياط على الاقتصاد نفسه بالذات في ظل
تراجع النمو الاقتصادي اصلا وتعطل النشاط
الاقتصادي بعد اشتعال شراره العمليات
العسكريه اللي اثرت على جميع جوانب
اقتصادهم بما في ذلك عمله الكيان المحتل
وهي الشكله يوم 10 اكتوبر اللي فات يعني
بعد ثلاث ايام من هجوم المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وبينما الاسرائيليين بيحاولوا
يفهموا ايه اللي بيحصل بدا الشكل يهبط
لادنى مستوى ليه من 2016 ووصل ل 3.9 شيكل
لكل دولار هنا المضاربين استغلوا
الاضطرابات وبداوا في فتح مراكز بيعه
المكشوف للشكل ولوه تدخل البنك المركزي
الاسرائيلي كانت العمله بتاعتهم زمانها
بتداس بالجزم دلوقتي البنك المركزي تدخل
بقوه وسرعه وبدا في تنفيذ اجراءات غير
مسبوقه علشان يمنع انهيار الشكل البنك
اعلن استعداده لبيع 30 مليار دولار من
الاحتياطيات اللي بيملكه لدعم العمله
بالاضافه لتمديد اتفاقيات مبادله ب 15
مليار دولار يعني بنتكلم عن 45 مليار
دولار لدعم الشكل بس ومنع انهياره ولكن
رغم المبلغ الضخم ده الا ان البنك المركزي
الاسرائيلي عنده ملاقه ماليه قويه قادره
تدافع عن الشاكل فوفقا لاحدث بيانات البنك
المركزي الاسرائيلي فحجم احتياطيات النقد
الاجنبي وصل ل18 90 وص مليار دولار في
نهايه شهر سبتمبر اللي فات ده الشيكل ما
كانش هو الوحيد اللي معمول عليه حفله لم
تكتمل ولكن تعرض الديون الاسرائيليه في
الاسواق الدوليه كان سلبي واتاثر بشده
علشان كده ارتفعت تكلفه التامين على
الديون السياديه لاسرائيل ضد التخلف عن
السداد لاعلى مستوى ليها من 14 سنه الاسهم
المرتبطه باسرائيل على مستوى العالم كانت
تحت النيران برده وتكبدت خسائر كبيره مش
بكلمك بس على الاسهم المحليه في البورصه
الاسرائيليه اللي انخفضت بنسبه
6.5% يوم 8 اكتوبر وهو اكبر انخفاض ليها
من اكث من ثلاث سنين ولكن بكلمك على
الاسهم الاسرائيليه في البورصات الاجنبيه
احنا بنتكلم عن اصول ب3 مليار دولار من
الاسهم والسندات الاسرائيليه اللي موجوده
في صناديق استثمار سواء صناديق سلبيه او
نشطه في البورصات الامريكيه ودي الصناديق
اللي عندها تعرض للاوراق الماليه
اسرائيليه باكتر من 70% بس من امثله
الصناديق اللي بتركز على اسرائيل مثلا
صندوق اي شيرز ام اس سي اي ازرا اي تي اف
وده خسران من يوم 6 اكتوبر ليوم 13 اكتوبر
99.7% وزي صندوق ارك ازرا انوفيت تكنولوجي
اي تي اف وده خسران
99.3% في نفس الفتره وصندوق تيموثي بلان
ازرا ك val ف وده خسران
8.9% في نفس الفتره دي عينه من الصناديق
المتداوله في البورصات الامريكيه واللي
بتضم اوراق ماليه اسرائيليه ومع استمرار
الحرب متوقع ان المستثمرين يهربوا منها
ويطلبوا من مدير الصندوق ريدمبشن او
الاسترداد يعني سداد الاوراق الماليه دي
ده غير اسهم الشركات اللي مقرها في
اسرائيل ومدرج في البورصات الامريكيه وفقا
للبيانات اللي جمعتها بلومبيرج ففي اكثر
من 100 شركه اسرائيليه مدرجه في البورصات
الامريكيه زي شركه الامن السيبراني تشيك
بوينت سوفت وير تكن
وبنك لومي الاسرايل ومورد الرقائق
الالكترونيه نوفا معظم اسهم الشركات
الاسرائيليه في البورصات الامريكيه خسرت
على مدار الايام اللي فاتت بشكل اجمالي في
بعض التقديرات المتحفظه اللي طلعت وبتقيس
تكاليف الحرب دي بالنسبه لاسرائيل وفقا
للتوقعات الاوليه ل بنك هابو عليم
فاسرائيل هتكلف 27 مليار شيكل او 6.8
مليار دولار او ما لا يقل عن
1.5% من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي في الحرب
الحاليه مع حركه حماس تقديرات البنك
بتستندل تكاليف الحروب السابقه اللي
خاضتها اسرائيل على سبيل المثال قدرت
تكاليف حرب لبنان الثانيه سنه 2006 واللي
استمرت 34 يوم حوالي 2.4 مليار دولار وفقا
لمعهد دراسات الامن القوم اينس اس عمليه
الرصاص المصبوب اللي كانت في ديسمبر 2008
ويناير 2009 اتقدرت تكلفتها ب 835 مليون
دولار في النهايه ما حدش يقدر يجزم ارقام
نهائيه للخسائر الاسرائيليه في الحرب دي
في الوقت الحالي لانها ببساطه لسه قائمه
وما فيش حد يقدر يتوقع تطوراتها لكنها
قطعا هتبقى بمليارات الدولارات في النهايه
والاهم نتمنى السلامه لاهلنا واخواننا في
قطاع غزه وفي كامل الاراضي الفلسطينيه
المحتله احنا معاكم وجنبكم انا كده خلصت
كلامي علشان ما اطولش على حضراتكم وقبل ما
اختم حابب ثاني بالنيابه عني وعن كل فريق
عمل المخبر الاقتصادي وجمهورنا اشكر جدا
شركه تلا فيت على رعايتها للحلقه دي
ومبادرتها الكريمه بالتبرع بمبلغ الرعايه
كاملا لدعم اهلنا في غزه بفكركم لو في
شركه او تاجر حابب يتعامل معاهم ويستورد
من خلالهم منتجاتهم لاكبر الاسواق العربيه
والسوق التركيه فهتلاقي تحت الفيديو
بياناتهم بفكركم بالتفاعل مع الفيديو
علشان يظهر للناس ويفلت من القيود الحاليه
لمنصات التواصل الاجتماعي كلها على اي
محتوى مناهض للكان المحتل
[موسيقى]
سلام